right the equation of the line that has
a slope of 1/3 and contains the point
negative 12 negative 14 thirds so the
equation of the line we can write as y
is equal to MX plus B this is in slope
intercept form where m is our slope and
B right over here is our y-intercept and
they have actually given us our slope
our slope they tell us is 1/3 so we know
that M is going to be 1/3 so we know
that Y is equal to 1/3 X plus B and so
now we just have to solve for B and the
way we can solve for B is that we know
this line contains the point negative 12
negative 14 over 3 so when X is equal to
negative 12 when X is equal to negative
twelve Y is equal to negative 14 over 3y
is equal to negative 14 over 3 so let's
write that down
negative 14 over 3 is going to be equal
to one third is going to be equal to 1/3
our slope times our x value which is
negative 12 times negative 12 and then
plus B plus B so when X is negative 12
we know that Y is equal to negative 14
thirds and we also know that the slope
is 1/3 that's the M and MX plus B so now
we can just solve for B the left-hand
side so I'll just leave it as negative
14 over 3 is equal to 1/3 times negative
12 1/3 times negative 12 is negative 4
so this is negative 4 plus B let me
write the plus B in that same color that
I started it with plus B plus looks like
a yellow color plus B and now just
isolate B on the right hand side we can
add 4 to both sides I want to get rid of
this negative 4 so let's add 4 to both
sides so plus 4 plus 4 we are left with
on the right hand side we're left with
just a B B is equal to on the left hand
side we have four four I can rewrite it
cuz I'm going up two I'm going to have
to add 4 to negative 14 over 3 so I want
a common denominator 4 is the same thing
as 12 over 3 so 4 is 12 over 3 minus 14
over 3 minus 14 over 3 so I just want to
be clear I just rewrote the 4 as 12 over
3 so 12 over 3 minus 14 over 3 or
negative 14 over 30 plus 12 over 3 is
going to give us well we have the same
denominator of 3 so we're going to have
3 12 minus 4 is negative 2 so we have
negative 2/3 is equal to B so the
equation of the line we figured out they
gave us a slope and now we just figured
out the y-intercept using this
information right over here so the
equation of our line is going to be y is
equal to 1/3 X we got the 1/3 from the
problem 1/3 X plus B B is negative 2/3
so I can just write minus 2 over 3 and
we are done